je suis je crois la seule candidate qui
a l'audace de dire qu'il va falloir
dépenser moins et travailler plus sur
une vie mais je crois que tout autre
discours est mensonger et qu'il faut
l'assumer
oui pourquoi il faut dépenser moins et
mieux l'argent public est bien parce que
la charge fiscale doit être allégé la
simplification doit devenir la priorité
des politiques publiques car je sais que
vous entendez dire ça depuis 15 ans nous
allons mettre en place un comité de la
hache certains disent que c'est brutal
mais au moins ça disent que ça veut dire
auprès du premier ministre pour
supprimer toutes les normes et
réduire la taille de tous les codes ont
recueilli efira les codes avec l'aide
des parlementaires il faut rendre
l'administration beaucoup plus facile
d'accès pour suivre le développement
l'administration numérique et créer des
guichet unique 2010chez dead aux
entreprises aujourd'hui en france 2000
je sais pas comment vous y retrouver
alors là aussi mon objectif il est clair
divisé par deux tous les délais de
traitement administratif c'est
l'objectif que s'est fixé le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz donc si nous ne
nous fixons pas le même alors nous ne
serons plus compétitifs par rapport à
l'allemagne il faut arrêter toutes les
surprend short transposition de
directives européennes et même regarder
rétroactivement si on peut revenir sur
des sur transposition déjà assez là
encore il faut que la france soit
compétitive pour peser à bruxelles on ne
respecte pas les pays qui sont
surendettés et les pays qui sont
déficitaires et on sait bien aujourd'hui
les normes à bruxelles elles sont fixés
d'abord par l'allemagne